2012年　ゴールデンウイーク
江南にて
ソウルに来て５日目
ホテルで出会ったジョンというごっついノルウェー人と江南を散策中
出発して３時間が経ったころ
「腹、減んない？」
僕はジョンに聞く。
「あぁ、なんか食べよう」
「和食なんかどう？」
「和食がなんだかよく分からんけど」
「カニと生きている物以外なら大丈夫」
「なら問題ない。行こう」
１０分後
ABIKO
と黒い文字で書かれたレストランを発見して
中に入る。
英語で挨拶してみると、いきなり
NO と言われたので、
「日本語出来ますか」と聞いてみる
すると、NOT JAPAN
「まあ落ち着いてミスター金」
と思いながら、 So Sorry と言って
２名という代わりにピースをする。
テーブルに着く。
チャン・グンソクにそっくりな女が現れ、水とも麦茶ともつかない飲み物とメニュー渡してきた。
各ページの最初だけ
前菜
定食
寿司
という風に漢字が書かれている。
それ以外は全部ハングルだ。
ふっとメニューから目を上げると、
ジョンの目が泳いでいる。
「どうする？」
「ここ、大丈夫？」
「絶対大丈夫」
「ちゃんとした和食レストランなら何を頼んでも外れはないから」
そう言った僕は「チョギョー」とグンソク女史を呼び、
定食のところに載っているジャパニーズで言えば１０００円の物を適当に指差す。
そして「Two」とゆっくり言いながら、またピースをする。
グンソクは「デー」と言って、厨房に消えた。
１０分後
生きたままのカニしかのっていない皿が運ばれてきた。